dans cette boulangerie contrairement aux
apparences les 900 baguette produite
aujourd'hui ne sont pas toutes réservées
à la clientèle
près d'une sur dix est en fait destiné à
un distributeur de pain dans un village
voisin
le boulanger peut gérer les stocks à
distance directement derrière ses
fourneaux
la machine est équipée d'une carte sim
donc on en voit à tout moment de la
journée un sms sur cette carte sim à la
machine dans un laps de temps de 30
secondes la machine va nous répondre la
quantité de baguettes présente encore
dans la machine sur les 50 baguette on
stocke un tiers est déjà vendue il est
temps de partir et approvisionner le
distributeur la machine se trouve à 4 km
de la boutique à turny le village n'a
plus de boulangerie car trop petit pour
intéresser les professionnels
alors le maire en personne est venu des
marchés l'artisan il ya plus d'un an
deux mois plus tard le distributeur est
mise en place succès immédiat auprès des
habitants depuis quel distributeur en
moins épais embêté à trouver du pain à
n'importe quelle heure ça quel avantage
c'est indispensable parce que manger
sans point moissac hommes
voilà ça sert à rien qu'on pratique pour
les habitants rentable pour cyril il
vend chaque jour 80 baguettes en moyenne
sont frais de main d'oeuvre ni de loyers
supplémentaires
on a voulu faire un test et puis force
est de constater que ça m'apporte ça
m'apporte des quantités supplémentaires
de production entre la boutique plus
plus la machine convaincu il veut
investir dans un deuxième distributeur
de pain dans les prochains mois s'il n'a
pas encore choisi le village où
l'installer le boulanger ne devrait pas
manquer de candidats